[Music]
in Margaret Atwood's near-future novel
The Handmaid's Tale a Christian
fundamentalist regime called the
Republic of Gilead has staged a military
coup and established a theocratic
government in the United States the
regime theoretically restricts everyone
but in practice a few men have
structured Gilead so they have all the
power
especially over women The Handmaid's
Tale is what atwood calls speculative
fiction meaning it theorizes about
possible futures this is a fundamental
characteristic shared by both utopian
and dystopian texts the possible futures
and Atwoods novels are usually negative
or dystopian where the actions of a
small group have destroyed society as we
know it
utopian and dystopian writing tends to
parallel political trends utopian
writing frequently depicts an idealized
society that the author puts forth as a
blueprint to strive toward dystopias on
the other hand are not necessarily
predictions of apocalyptic futures but
rather warnings about the ways in which
societies can set themselves on the path
to destruction The Handmaid's Tale was
published in 1985 when many conservative
groups attacked the gains made by the
second wave feminist movement this
movement had been advocating greater
social and legal equality for women
since the early 1960s The Handmaid's
Tale imagines a future in which the
conservative counter movement gains the
upper hand and not only demolishes the
progress women had made toward equality
but makes women completely subservient
to men
Gilead divides women in the regime into
distinct social classes based upon their
function as status symbols for men even
their clothing is color-coded women are
no longer allowed to read or move about
freely in public and fertile women are
subject to state engineered rape in
order to give birth to children for the
regime although The Handmaid's Tale is
set in the future one of atwood's
self-imposed rules in writing it was
that she wouldn't use any event or
practice that hadn't already happened in
human history the book is set in
Cambridge Massachusetts a city that
during the American colonial period had
been ruled by the theocratic Puritans in
many ways the Republic of Gilead
resembles the strict rules that were
present in Puritan society rigid moral
codes modest clothing banishment of
dissenters and regulation of every
aspect of people's lives and
relationships for atwood the parallels
to massachusetts Puritans were personal
as well as theoretical she spent several
years studying the Puritans at Harvard
and she's possibly descended from Mary
Webster a Puritan woman accused of
witchcraft who survived her hanging
atwood is a master storyteller the
details of gilead which we've only
skimmed the surface of slowly come into
focus through the eyes of its characters
mainly the novel's protagonist offered a
handmaid in the household of a commander
before the coup that established Gilead
offered had a husband a child a job and
a normal middle-class American life but
when the fundamentalist regime comes
into power Offred has denied her
identity separated from her family and
reduced to being in off words words a
two-legged womb for increasing Gilly
odds waning population she initially
accepts the loss of her fundamental
human rights in the name of stabilizing
the new government but state control
soon extends into attempts to control
the language behavior and thoughts of
herself and other individuals early on
offered says I wait I compose myself my
self is a thing I must compose as one
composes a speech she likens language to
the formulation of identity her words
also acknowledge the possibility of
resistance and its resistance the
actions of people who dare to break the
political intellectual and sexual rules
that drives the plot of The Handmaid's
Tale ultimately the novel's exploration
of the consequences of complacency and
how power can be wielded unfairly makes
Atwoods chilling vision of a dystopian
regime ever relevant you can download an
audio version of this book or any other
book on the ted-ed book rex lists by
visiting audible.com slash ted-ed every
free trial encourages audible to
continue supporting our nonprofit
mission thanks for watching and thanks
for your support